Y si os dijera que hay un país en Europa
que está ganando dinero con la crisis
energética un país democrático miembro
de la otan y que tiene gas y petróleo a
raudales Exacto hablamos de Noruega el
país de los salmones y del black metal
tras el cierre del gas ruso son muchas
las miradas que están puestas en Noruega
un país que hasta ahora era la segunda
fuente de gas natural para Europa por
detrás de Rusia Pero la pregunta del
millón de dólares es será capaz Noruega
de salvar a Europa con su gas natural
sea como sea lo que está claro es que
Noruega se está haciendo aún más rica
con la guerra y esto es importante
porque Noruega no solo es un país
importante por el petróleo además tiene
un enorme peso en el mundo de la empresa
habéis oído bien
pesa que tienen un poco más de 5
millones de habitantes el estado noruego
tiene uno de los fondos de inversión más
grandes del mundo el fondo soberano
noruego Bonaparte de los beneficios que
ganan con los combustibles fósiles se
invierten en activos a lo largo y ancho
de todo el planeta tierra plantas de
energías renovables deuda y muebles y
acciones de Las mayores empresas del
planeta y todo esto puede llegar a tener
importantes consecuencias para el día a
día de todos nosotros Incluso en ámbitos
que quizás nunca sospecharíamos que
tiene que ver Noruega por ejemplo con
las fake news de Facebook que tiene que
ver Noruega con las luchas sindicales en
Amazon no me he vuelto loco al final de
este vídeo entenderéis Por qué todo lo
que ocurre en Noruega puede llegar a
tener consecuencias en Wall Street y en
nuestra vida diaria
por supuesto No han faltado tampoco
quienes los han acusado de egoístas Como
por ejemplo el Primer Ministro polaco
pero en Noruega lo de que no te hace
rico regalando el dinero lo sabe muy
bien De hecho a pesar de ser un gran
país petrolero tienen uno de los precios
de la gasolina más altos del mundo Así
que las preguntas que nos hacemos son
Cómo está afectando la Guerra de Ucrania
a los noruegos Qué impacto puede tener
todo esto en la economía mundial hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes vamos a hablar de internet como
sabéis internet está lleno de hackers y
de cookies que francamente no queremos
tener y además cada vez más
restricciones queréis ver páginas web de
cualquier país sin ningún bloqueo
queréis navegar por internet con
seguridad pues no lo penséis más usad
una VPN como surfshark VPN creedme el
tema de seguridad se lo toma muy en
serio de hecho sushark es la primera VPN
comercial que puede presumir de tener
servidores en más de 100 países
distintos pero no solo eso surfshark
tiene una herramienta que se llama
cleanweb que bloquea todos los popups de
propaganda por donde se cuelan todos
esos y esas cookies que no queremos
tener por si todo esto fuera poco con
una única cuenta de surfshark VPN
podréis registrar todos los dispositivos
que queráis queréis navegar con
seguridad desde vuestra Smart TV o desde
el teléfono móvil o desde el ordenador
pues podéis hacer todo esto con una
única cuenta de surfshark VPN Y por
supuesto tenemos una oferta muy especial
para Black Friday y en general el
periodo de vacaciones que va a ser muy
especial para todos los que seguís
visualpolitik si utilizáis el código
politik terminado en K podréis disfrutar
de un 85% de descuento más tres meses
extra totalmente gratuitos tenéis el
link en la descripción esta oferta
estará vigente desde el 1 de noviembre
hasta el 31 de diciembre de 2022 Así que
no esperéis más que a veces estas cosas
las dejamos pasar y cuando nos queremos
dar cuenta es demasiado tarde entrar Ya
en la web y Descargar la aplicación y
ahora sí vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
la excepción Noruega
no logras actualmente el mayor
exportador de salmón del mundo exporta a
más de 100 países pero no solo exportan
salmón Noruega es también uno de los
grandes productores de zumo de
dinosaurio y de gas natural Aunque a
todos nos gusta el salmón son los
hidrocarburos los que representan entre
un 40 y un 70% de las exportaciones de
Noruega y lo que ha hecho que Noruega
sea un país tan rico no fue nada fácil
encontrar petróleo en Noruega Durante
los años 60 hicieron más de 200
perforaciones hasta encontrar un
yacimiento el yacimiento petrolero de
ecofisk y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando
muchos sobre todo los que ya conozcáis
nuestro canal hermano visual económico
un país descubre petróleo cuidado pueden
caer en la famosa maldición de los
recursos naturales Exacto tener mucha
recursos naturales no implica ser rico
en muchos casos ocurre justo lo
contrario Pero de todo esto lo
explicamos con más detalle en un vídeo
de visualpolitik que por supuesto os
dejo en la descripción sin embargo
Noruega no es ni Rusia ni Venezuela es
un caso muy especial atentos
[Música]
en 1972 Noruega creó la empresa Estatal
de petróleo esteitoil que ahora se llama
equinor en 2001 steady sacó a cotizar
parte de sus acciones en las bolsas de
oslo y Nueva York pero el gobierno
siguió teniendo el 81,7% de la propiedad
luego en 2007 llegaría una fusión con la
división de petróleo y gas de hidro el
principal productor de energía
hidroeléctrica de Noruega ahora mismo el
estado noruego es propietario de algo
más del 68% de equinor por supuesto esta
empresa reparte dividendos que son
cobrados mayoritariamente por el
gobierno noruego Claro que no es la
única vía de ingresos públicas el
gobierno noruego también es copropitario
de muchos de los yacimientos de gas y
petróleo del país al tiempo que los
impuestos sobre los beneficios
procedentes de la explotación del crudo
son altísimos en concreto el estado se
puede llegar a quedar con más del 75% de
los beneficios es decir que si hablamos
de petróleo en Noruega el mayor
beneficiario siempre siempre es el
estado
y la pregunta es Pero quién han hecho
con todo ese dinero
Pues bien en 1990 Noruega creó el
llamado fondo soberano noruego un fondo
de inversión Estatal con el propósito de
invertir los excedentes de los ingresos
del petróleo y el gas y diréis por qué
Pues porque este fondo soberano
amortigua a todas las crisis que baja el
precio del petróleo no hay problema
Noruega tiene inversiones En toda clases
de activos activos que por supuesto no
tienen nada que ver con el petróleo este
fondo está gestionado por una división
del Banco Central de Noruega lo que a
muchos os puede sorprender es que el
fondo soberano de Noruega es el fondo
soberano más grande del mundo junto con
el fondo principal de China y el fondo
de abu dhabi atentos a esta gráfica
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea en 2013 este
fondo representaba el equivalente al
183% y en 2022 ya representa más del
225% del pib noruego pero no solo eso A
diferencia de los programas públicos de
otros países este fondo ha tenido un
crecimiento casi constante incluso han
obtenido importantes retornos tras la
pandemia del covid y los bajos precios
del petróleo que hubo en 2020 y os
preguntaréis Pero cuánto petróleo
produce Noruega pues lo cierto Es que no
demasiado
a nivel mundial Noruega produce
aproximadamente el 2% del petróleo que
se consume y el 3% del gas muy por
detrás de lo que producen países como
Estados Unidos Rusia Canadá o Brasil
entre otros muchos para que os hagáis
una idea en 2021 ahora había estado y
produjo en torno a 9 millones de
barriles de petróleo Estados Unidos 11
millones Canadá 4,7 millones y Noruega
aproximadamente 1,7 millones de barriles
Eso sí en lo que respecta al gas Noruega
es el tercer mayor exportador de todo el
planeta tan solo por detrás de Rusia y
de Qatar
en cualquier caso su diferencia su
secreto respecto a otros países se ha
basado en ser uno de los pocos países
que invierten bolsa y diversifica sus
ganancias del petróleo y el gas natural
de esta forma el gobierno está
prácticamente garantizando el futuro de
los noruegos Y es que fijaos por Norma
general los gobiernos son deudores netos
es decir tienen deudas con el resto del
mundo por ejemplo en el caso de Estados
Unidos la deuda pública equivale unos 93
mil dólares por Cada ciudadano
estadounidense en el caso de Italia
equivale a más de 50.000 y en el caso de
España a más de 30.000 Pues bien en
Noruega las situaciones completamente
distintas sabéis cuánto pagaría cada
noruego de deuda pública absolutamente
nada podrían pagar toda la deuda pública
del país con el dinero del fondo
soberano y aún así le sobraría más de
180 mil dólares por cada noruego
tanto los partidos de derechas como los
de izquierdas han sido muy conservadores
con el fondo y no lo han derrochado algo
difícil de imaginar en otros países
donde llegar al poder muchas veces
supone un reparto del botín para ganar
votos la primera retirada de dinero del
fondo soberano se produjo en 2016 cuando
se gastaron 780 millones de dólares para
contrarrestar una recesión económica
causada por los bajos precios del
petróleo de esta forma Noruega apenas
notó esa crisis del petróleo dicho de
otra forma para que nos entendamos Que
si se produce una nueva crisis del
petróleo que hiciera sufrir mucho a
otros países productores Noruega no
tendría ni que notar esa crisis pero
queréis un dato que os va a hacer
estallar la cabeza Pues veréis en 2021
el gobierno de noruego ingresó unos
30.000 millones de dólares gracias a la
explotación de petróleo del país pues
bien la rentabilidad media del fondo
soberano noruego en torno a un 5,8%
desde su creación supone que en un año
típico el estado gana más del doble con
los beneficios del fondo que con los
propios ingresos del petróleo En otras
palabras que en Noruega ya es más
dependiente del fondo que del petróleo
el gran ahorro que salva Noruega de la
crisis petrolera pero más allá de ser
muy ricos La pregunta es de verdad
pueden Noruega ser la salvación de
Europa que se dirige al gas macedon pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
Noruega al rescate
Noruega hallaron un socio clave de la
Unión Europea antes de la Guerra de
Ucrania exportaba el 20% de la demanda
de gas natural en Europa hasta el año
pasado Bruselas pedía oslo que dejara de
perforar en el Ártico por razones
ecológicas ahora bien Bruselas en estos
momentos está pidiendo a oslo que saque
petroligas de donde puedan es decir que
ahora el tema del cambio climático es un
poco secundario el objetivo es
reemplazar el gas ruso con más gas
noruego y de otros países de momento
Noruega ya se ha comprometido aumentar
las exportaciones a Europa para hacer
frente a la crisis energética Noruega
elevará un 6,8% su producción de
hidrocarburos para el 2023 Hablamos de
un incremento que se suma al que ya han
tenido durante el 2022 Durante este año
Noruega producirá un 8% más de gas
natural que en 2021 en total el
incremento en la producción de petróleo
y de gas será de casi un 15% en 2021 y
dio un 6,8% en 2023 casi un 23% en
apenas dos años Así que si hablamos
nuevamente como conspiranoicos podéis
adivinar Cuál es el país europeo que más
se ha beneficiado de las sanciones al
gas Ruso y del Sabotaje extremo 1 Exacto
Noruega
casualmente un nuevo caso ducto noruego
se ha puesto en funcionamiento desde el
1 de octubre el gasoducto se llama
baltic y ya ha empezado a consumir gas
desde Noruega hasta Polonia pasando por
Dinamarca el gasoducto baltic
transportará 10 bcms de gas al año hacia
Polonia si hasta ahora Noruega
satisfacía el 20% de la demanda Europea
de gas este año se calcula que ya
estaría cubriendo un 25%. y se espera
que para el año que viene el porcentaje
sea aún mayor Es más desde el propio
gobierno de Noruega dicen lo siguiente
ellos Europa necesitarán gas de otras
fuentes además de Rusia creo que es
difícil ver muchos lugares desde donde
sea más natural seguir importando gas en
un contexto europeo que el de Noruega
para nosotros es importante que sepan y
les demostremos que Noruega son socio
energético fiable digno de confianza y a
largo plazo para Europa Andrés jalón
ericser secretario de estado del
Ministerio de petróleo y energía de
Noruega y equinor y ha dicho que va a
subir la producción pero esperad un
momento porque si bien Noruega está
dando un pequeño respiro Europa con su
gas magedón no será la solución
definitiva al menos de momento
[Música]
a veces querer no es poder y en noruegas
están frotando las manos con todos estos
ingresos extras y quieren por supuesto
vender más gas a Europa necesitada el
problema El problema es que Noruega no
puede duplicar su producción de gas de
un día para otro No solo eso antes de la
guerra había quien incluso decía que
había que dejar de extraer hidrocarburos
Tan pronto como en 2035 vale Este era el
caso de los verdes pero ojo porque el
propio partido de laborista que es quien
está ahora en el gobierno no ponía una
fecha concreta pero era a partir de área
de negociarlo es decir que tampoco es
que hubiera muchos incentivos para
invertir en la industria petrolera y
gasista del país dicho de otra forma es
imposible dar la vuelta en unos pocos
meses a años de desinversión además algo
que ha dificultado la compra de gas en
Europa es la capacidad Europea de
regasificación una forma rápida de
abastecer el suministro de gas es como
ya sabéis comprar gas natural licuado no
habría que esperar a construir nuevos
gasoductos con Noruega ni con otros
países pero la capacidad de
reclasificación de la Unión Europea no
es suficiente Alemania que es el país
que más gas consume de la Unión Europea
no tenía ni una sola planta de
regasificación antes de la Guerra de
Ucrania y por supuesto Noruega tampoco
tiene la suficiente capacidad de
licuefacción porque el gnl Primero se
tiene que helicobactar para luego
recasificarlo es decir que necesitas
capacidad en los dos extremos de la
cadena de transporte dicho de otra forma
que Europa necesita mucho más Gas del
que Noruega puede ofrecer al menos en el
corto plazo en otros vídeos de visual
político os explicamos más en detalle
que es el gas natural licuado y cuáles
son las diferentes alternativas que
Europa está consiguiendo para intentar
contrarrestar la crisis energética
Europa está diversificando en la compra
de gas y preparándose para recibir más
gas natural licuado de diferentes países
pero ahora la pregunta es en Noruega
están siendo solidarios o hay algún
interés detrás existía algún oscuro plan
globalista detrás de todo esto Pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
el Monopoly de Noruega
como ya os hemos dicho al principio del
vídeo Noruega está ganando muchísimo
dinero con el tema de la guerra en
Ucrania vamos que se están haciendo de
oros sin tener que ir a saquear como el
vikingo Olaf Qué significa todo esto
para el fondo soberano de Noruega y para
la economía mundial pues ojo porque solo
en 2023 el gobierno noruego espera
ingresar gracias a la explotación del
crudo y Obras natural más de 130
millones de dólares y eso no es todo de
momento los ingresos de 2022 se estiman
en casi 120.000 millones de dólares y
sabéis cuánto ingresaron en 2021 Pues
algo menos de 30.000 millones es decir
gracias a la Guerra de Ucrania Noruega
va a ingresar en 2022 y 2023 el
equivalente a 8 años normales y sabéis
Qué gran parte de estos ingresos serán
destinados para su fondo soberano Y esto
no es ninguna broma porque Noruega es ya
la dueña del 1,3% de todas las acciones
que hay en el mundo empresas como Nestlé
Apple o Microsoft tienen al fondo
soberano luego como uno de sus mayores
accionistas y atentos porque aquí llega
lo realmente interesante una ventaja de
ser accionista de una empresa es que si
tienes la suficiente acciones puedes
llegar a influ en el rumbo de la
corporación Pues bien hasta hace unos
años este fondo soberano no perseguía
ninguna influencia en las empresas en
las que invertía digamos que se limitaba
a excluir cierto tipo de empresas de su
cartera básicamente fabricantes de armas
productores de hidrocarburos tabaco
carbón o empresas con dudosos vínculos
con los Derechos Humanos algo que por
supuesto todavía sigue haciendo
[Música]
por ejemplo recientemente el fondo puso
a la canadiense de Bombardier y a la
surcoreana Hyundai globes en una lista
de vigilancia para la posible venta de
su inversión en el caso de Hyundai fue
debido al supuesto uso de desguaces en
Pakistán y bangladesh donde las
condiciones laborales rozan la violación
de Derechos Humanos al menos según el
fondo en el caso de Bombardier la razón
fueron algunas sospechas de corrupción
en diferentes países luego este mismo
fondo también ha tenido polémicas con el
gobierno chino por ejemplo se
deshicieron de todas las acciones en la
empresa deportiva lining debido a una
aparente violación de los Derechos
Humanos en la región de singyang
sin embargo desde algún tiempo la
estrategia del fondo a comenzado a
cambiar hemos evolucionado de ser un
propietario reacio a un propietario más
activo al principio la idea era
simplemente comprar una porción de los
mercados financieros globales y nuestra
intención no era ejercer ninguna
influencia sobre las empresas tron
grande subdirector ejecutivo del fondo
soberano de Noruega por ejemplo ya no
resulta tan extraño para generar presión
que este fondo publique por adelantado
que va a votar sobre determinados temas
en las juntas de accionistas y
supuestamente lo hacen para mejorar el
gobierno de las empresas Nuestro
objetivo es fortalecer a las empresas
mediante una mejor gobernanza y mejorar
su gestión de los riesgos a largo plazo
tron grandes subdirector ejecutivo del
fondo soberano de Noruega en esta línea
en el año 2021 el fondo soberano noruego
votó en seis resoluciones en la junta de
accionistas de Facebook para que esta
empresa fuera más transparente y
presentar informes mejorados sin embargo
justo Aquí está la cuestión
potencialmente más inquietante que de
cuestiones meramente corporativas el
fondo noruego pase a presionar a las
empresas con cuestiones más
identitarias o políticas es decir que
trata de importar los valores noruegos a
las empresas en las que invierte por
ejemplo en 2022 el fondo noruego votó a
favor de realizar un informe de derechos
humanos y realizar un informe sobre la
brecha salarial en la junta de
accionistas de Disney y algo parecido
ocurrió en Amazon
[Música]
Noruega estuvo del lado de los
trabajadores de Amazon que querían
montar un sindicato de hecho en una
junta de finistas Noruega votó a favor
del derecho de negociación colectiva en
contra de los intereses del mismísimo
Jeff bezos como curiosidad os diré que
en este caso Noruega perdió la votación
y lo hizo entre otras cosas porque las
participaciones del fondo en las
empresas suelen ser relativamente
pequeñas pero claro cuando tienes tanto
dinero lo que dices dentro de una
empresa al menos se escucha Y además
puedes llegar a marcar tendencia muchos
otros fondos y accionistas pueden
decidir copiarte para entendernos
podemos decir que Noruega en la bolsa es
como la chica Popular en el colegio que
marca tendencias y no solo eso llegado
el caso este fondo podría comprar
participaciones más grandes en
determinadas empresas para así ampliar
su cuota de influencia podríamos decir
que con más de un billón de dólares en
tu cartera de inversión y decimos billón
en castellano en inglés sería trillions
puedes hacer prácticamente lo que
quieras siréis otro ejemplo pues veréis
Noruega no solo es uno de los países más
ricos del mundo también es uno de los
más igualitarios y es precisamente
modelo social el que intentan llevar a
sus empresas de hecho sabéis Cuál es una
de las grandes causas por las que luchan
Noruega Exacto el sueldo de los
directivos Noruega Lleva años
presionando las empresas para que bajen
todos esos sueldazos que pagan a sus
directivos esto significa una cosa el
fondo soberano noruego puede terminar
convirtiéndose en todo una pesadilla
para los ceos Por eso nos sorprenderán
titulares como este el mayor foto
soberano del mundo votará contra el
paquete salarial del ceo de Apple Tim
Cook y ojo porque el problema es que
puedes empezar con el salario de los
directivos y terminar con muchas otras
iniciativas digamos que llegado el caso
Noruega puede usar el fondo como un arma
política en una dirección o en otra
[Música]
sin ir más lejos este año el fondo
anunció que liquidará todos sus activos
rusos hablamos en este caso de unos
2.800 millones de dólares no es una gran
suma si lo comparamos con las invasiones
que tienen en otros países pero ahí
queda y lógicamente Cuanto más dinero
tenga el fondo mayor Será su influencia
Así que si algo está claro es que ese
enorme torrente de dinero que ahora está
entrando a raudales en el país de los
fiordos si algo va a hacer es
precisamente incrementar esa influencia
ojo también hay quienes han criticado
duramente toda esta forma de comportarse
del fondo soberano noruego Y diréis por
qué Pues porque perseguir intereses
políticos o ideológicos a la hora de
invertir puede resultar también en
pérdidas de rentabilidad y esto pueden
ser malas noticias para los propios
ciudadanos noruegos Claro que he puesto
salvar de críticas Noruega también ha
recibido fuertes críticas por los
grandes ingresos que están obteniendo
gracias a la guerra el propio Primer
Ministro de Polonia ha señalado que
Noruega se está beneficiando
directamente de la guerra y los ha
instado a compartir esta nueva riqueza
con Ucrania pero sea como sea La
pregunta es para vosotros ayudarán más
Ucrania o buscarán invertir más en su
fondo soberano conseguirán Noruega
producir más gas natural para salvar a
Europa de la crisis energética Cuáles
serán los próximos movimientos del fondo
soberano noruego podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis Que aquí en
visualpolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos
Todas las semanas así que suscribíos a
este canal y dadle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto